denise valdez as the pandemic continues
to really put a lot of shortages
in many different industries the red
cross says now the shortage of blood
right now is prompting the organization
to now issue a crisis alert joe mohler
live near flamingo and maryland parkway
with the problems red cross and other
organizations are facing joe
red cross does not only need more people
to donate blood but they also need more
places to host blood drives today one
did happen here at the clark county
library a representative from red cross
says it's proving to be difficult to
find places to host these blood drives
they called me and asked there's been a
severe shortage of blood due to the
covid christine goran wanted to help
after the red cross called her about the
crisis not as many places they're
hosting and i always like to do my part
the pandemic has created a few problems
less staff and fewer locations to host
blood drives right now we're in a blood
crisis keith paul with the red cross
says there is a one-day supply of blood
severe weather has impacted other areas
of the country and the pandemic has
created a slew of issues some of it is
staffing we used to have a lot of blood
drives in high schools and colleges
those have not come back yet we've had
drives and many
businesses that have not reopened or
have gone 100 percent remote while umc
here locally has not felt the pinch a
hospital in southern california was
forced to close its trauma center for a
few hours due to the shortage right now
we are at about less than one day's
supply of butt we're working with the
hospitals around the clock to ensure
that they get enough blood i also
reached out to by talent another leading
blood donation organization they too
aren't nearing crisis levels it's the
one little thing i can do for somebody
brandi sherman says the virus is what
pushed her to start donating the red
cross is asking more people to do the
same i did get the phone call that they
were out of o positive which is what i
am so here i am today
[Music]
now they were working with a few
companies to offer incentives like an
amazon gift card and a free dozen krispy
kreme donuts for those who donated blood
if you are interested in donating blood
or if you wanted to host a blood drive
just head to our website for the link to
do so reporting live joe mohler live
local now